so full of there's so much evidence
that he's corrupt just undeniable
evidence of corruption hey guys I'm off
the grid for August but little-known
podcaster Joe Rogan just did something
that's culturally relevant I just can't
imagine the United States wants
president Kamala Harris I don't think
anybody wants that nobody wants that I
mean they've made maybe some people
would prefer that over president Trump
but nobody wants that nobody wants
president Newsome either nobody believes
in that guy that guy's a con man I
mean everything he did in California
from trying to mandate vaccines for kids
what is totally unnecessary to being
caught out in public without a mask and
lying about the fact that he was
Outdoors yeah all of it it's just nobody
believes in that guy he's just a
politician just a stone cold narrative
driven politician you know and it's
nobody thinks he's a real human whether
you like Trump or not whether you think
it's he's corrupt or not that's a human
being you you know you know is you know
what that guy is same thing with RFK Jr
whether you believe that he's correct
about vaccines or whether you believe
his policies would be effective and you
know that's a human being with Newsome
you've got like this construct
this this cardboard cutout of a person
it's just I don't think people want that
but they might want it more than they
want president Trump and that's where we
got Joe Biden we didn't get Joe Biden
because Joe Biden's Amazing Joe Biden's
been a goof his whole career
he's always been a goof he's always been
he's been caught lying so many times
he's so full of there's so much
evidence that he's corrupt just
undeniable evidence of corruption and
the stuff with him and his son and then
the guy who just testified that was
business partners with with Hunter who
talked about all the different things
that Joe was involved with Kevin Archer
yeah
it's
it's undeniable and the fact that they
that mainstream news is ignoring this
except for right-wing media it's crazy